let's go to Tommy in the 202 who we have
flagged as an anti Biden guy Tommy where
are you at these days back man so what's
up that you know Democrats are monsters
and that after that stunt they pulled
yesterday I
I am absolutely disgusted by their by
that you know I mean which stunt you
mean just like voting when there's a
virus yes right right yeah I mean listen
yeah how do you have a president saying
you shouldn't gather in groups of more
than ten and then you have a couple
million people voting I just don't get
it I don't understand you know it's it's
crazy I mean in many ways they kind of
just listen I'm at this point the
Democrats are just basically in the same
type of breed of monsters that these
Republicans are you could say that yeah
well at the very least Republicans are
still kind of worse with certain with
some of the things that they do brain
boys eat eat I'm jingling disgusted
right now and I'm like you know what I'm
looking at the situation about Bernie's
vote and Bernie's uh a reason for
failures at this point I got like five
reasons why he failed number one that in
that endorsement wave they came with all
the the people dropping out and going to
support Joe Biden got number two there's
mainstream media brainwashing that keeps
happening with wonderful I literally got
a family member out here with things
straight up Joe Biden's a whole anti
social security history thing that
there's been obfuscated that is far a
bit more complicating it is and I'm like
I literally have video evidence of him
lying about that bro how you how are you
not seeing that um then we got
situations of older voter turnout and
it's like where happened to the youth
right I'm thinking then maybe did you
know what because as far as I understand
it the stats said straight up the youth
turnout was basically a similar to
happen four years ago with the last
Vernie election versus the older turnout
which is just everybody's just coming in
and math
I don't understand how that happened I
read I genuinely don't understand that
and that means me to think that there's
probably some more truth to this whole
thing by fourth reason rigged because
look I understand that's a dirty word
for a lot of people but you know what
first off that Iowa situation yeah
there's no other explanation for that
after that one when you say we're not
even gonna correct the record it's all
okay now hold on a second because you
are shot out of a cannon today and let
me see if we can maybe diffuse a little
bit the one thing I want to ask you is
does does Bernie bear any responsibility
in the sense that like do you think
Bernie benefited or not from the
Democratic Socialist label what do you
think of that as it's just an example oh
yeah that's that's actually my sis
reason okay Bernie Sanders - nice let's
not mince words
- nice versus saying you're a Democratic
Socialist those are two different things
right like I believe it was damaging to
keep going with that label I've been
saying it for five years do you agree
that self-inflicted right yeah I've read
that but I also think that straight up
in a way when I say two nights I mean
that you need to more aggressively say
the problems of with love abide in the
presidency versus a Bernie presidency
and like how Kyle was saying you need to
make the case that I'm the moderate I'm
the censors I'm the one who's actually
got more your interest at heart
because I have no interest at heart I'm
better at the in Donald Trump one other
question Tommy again I just I'm trying
to hear where your head's at in every
poll over the last two weeks that does a
hypothetical matchup Biden versus Trump
and Bernie versus Trump Biden performs
better do you think those polls are just
wrong are people lying when they respond
to the pollsters that means this way at
this point all the Trump I think is the
favorite to win
well our least chunk has a better
chances of winning based on the things
that happened whether he's going against
Bernie or Joe Biden I think Bernie has a
better chance of beating Donald Trump
because again Joe Biden he's running on
the type of platform that Clinton did
back in 2016 the wrong type of platform
that John Kerry did back in 2004
that's a risk okay right Oh cause I'm
concerned I'm like it built those poles
especially because of how close they are
you're not of them I'm just like who you
voting for in November you know what
that is what I'm mad at this boy Joe
Biden it's me
East to conserve it I'm sorry but I'm
gonna have to disagree with you when it
comes to like state Supreme Court picks
and climate change
that's who you only gain November who
you voting for November Joe Biden better
come get my vote because here's the
thing
it ain't this thing what he has going
for him is the fact that he's better at
health care than all truck right more
people will probably be covered under
him than Donald Trump
he better not move to the right on that
okay and from the 202 always great to
hear from you my friend all right
Tommy's underwhelmed there with my wrap
up of his uh his phone call okay let's
go next to the seven seven three area
code who's calling today from 773
I am and who's this this is Michael
Michael what's up so um I was
disappointed that some of my fellow
Bernie bros are voting for Donald Trump
if he doesn't win I don't think they
should do that if who doesn't win
Bernie Bernie winning right now no it's
over it's over yeah mmm yeah when I
heard you say it's over I was
disappointed but yeah so no I was about
who are you voting for in the in
November I not old enough to vote for
the fight was either vote for to fight
in I know one look Trump right I think
that's the right that's the right
attitude
Michael all right yep how you holding up
with the virus
I'm singing home however I did get some
work from my school you did and it's
cool hell yeah are you Michael
hmm how old a guy are you one more time
what's your age Michael how old of a
person are you I'm only 15
you're 16 okay so your whole like high
school is canceled for the rest of what
the semester the year um
it's canceled until March of 30 if I
think oh and then they're gonna
re-evaluate and then yeah all right
Michael very good anything else you
wanted to mention today mmm try to be
scared of the coronavirus should you be
scared did you say yeah well it's not
about being scared it's about being
cautious and acting responsibly so when
when we're told listen limit your
exposure unless necessary stay home so
on and so forth it's not about you know
being scared won't do anything for you
but being cautious and having a plan
will and it sounds like you're doing
that by you know doing school work from
home and all of that yeah okay Michael
thanks very much excellent to hear from
Michael in the 7/7 three area code if
you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time check out one of my
all-time favorite apps called blink its
blink Isleta consumed an entire book on
your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinken
blink East has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video